heute geht es mal um das Thema Location
für eine eventuelle Staffel 2 wo machen
wir das ganze wir sind auf der Suche
nach
Kontaktpersonen die uns eventuell dabei
helfen können eine passende Location zu
finden and out aber wie zur Hölle findet
man genauso einen Standort welche
Kriterien muss er erfüllen und vor allem
aber was passiert wenn kurz vor
Produktionsstart eine dunkle
Vergangenheit ans Tageslicht zu planen
[Applaus]
wenn ich das währenddessen ins gefällt
und die uns unterstützen wollt dann
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
um keinen der weiteren Folgen zu
verpassen servus waldstaffel 1 ist wie
wir alle wissen grandios gelaufen darauf
folgend ist uns auch schnell klar
geworden dass wir relativ früh in die
Konzeptionierung von der Staffel 2 gehen
wollten Januar diesen Jahres sind wir
halt schon in die ersten Meetings
gegangen und ja hatten schon was auf dem
Zettel stehen eigentlich eigentlich gibt
es nur zwei Sachen die geändert werden
müssen stand jetzt einmal neue
Teilnehmer und die zweite Sache die hast
du gerade schon gesagt die erinnert
werden müsste ist die Location ja was
machen wir anders was wollen wir ändern
und da sind wir sehr sehr schnell zu dem
Schluss gekommen okay wir müssen
natürlich in den kompletten Location
Switch machen was ist das woran man als
erstes denkt natürlich Robinson cruso
einsame Insel irgendwie allein
gestrandet Schiffbruch was weiß ich
haben dann tatsächlich auch zu dritt
versucht selber so zu scouten ein
bisschen Google Maps Google Earth mal so
ein bisschen geguckt was könnte gehen
und ja da haben sich dann so schnell so
viele Probleme aufgetan weil ey dann
findest du eine Insel die finster geil
was machst Rudern guckst du in
irgendwelche Verzeichnissen wo ist diese
Insel wer besitzt diese Insel faxt sie
an und ich habe dann auch mal so Portale
für Superreiche gefunden
halt wirklich guckt ja wir hatten diese
Insel die irgendwie 100 Millionen kostet
soll ich dir mal fragen ob wir da ein
bisschen Filmen dürfen so ist natürlich
irgendwie Quatsch und auch absur das
heißt da haben wir dann sehr schnell
gemerkt wir brauchen da Hilfe und haben
dann diesen Aufruf gestartet weil ja wir
haben einfach keinen vernünftigen Weg
gefunden wie man sowas dann strukturiert
machen kann dieses ganze Projekt eine
eventuell zweiten Staffel steht und
fällt einfach mit der Location ich bin
eigentlich der Meinung dass ich das
ganze nicht wieder in Schweden machen
will ich danke für eure Mithilfe over
and out
ja hi wir sind Ton Martin von wandermut
und wir organisieren und planen
Abenteuer und Expeditionen an ihren
blickten Winkel dieser Erde und das hat
uns schon so ziemlich überall hingeführt
ob es jetzt Husky Tour in Russland sind
mit Macheten durch Amazonas Regenwald
auf ruinensuche oder eben hier in die
komplette Planung und Organisation und
konsequide nach unserem Videoaufruf
haben sich super viele Leute gemeldet
super viele Firmen gemeldet aber einer
hat besonders heraus gestochen das war
wandermut die direkt gesagt haben hey
wir sind die richtigen für euch wir sind
gerade einer an einer ähnlichen Sache
dran und haben schon Inseln gescoutet
und wissen glaube ich was was ihr wollt
guck mir das Video abends an schau auf
die Locations hier da zeigt und darunter
war halt auch eine Insel im Panama und
ich dachte mir oh mein Gott also wir
haben echt die Insel genau 5 km weiter
das ist doch das Ding das haben wir
schon seit zwei Jahren vor so wir hatten
das schon geplant wir hatten Helikopter
Piloten also Kontakte hier auch survival
Profis wir hatten sogar schon eine Insel
rausgesucht ja und haben wir Fritz quasi
angeschrieben auf allen Kanälen gesagt
ey wir sind genau deine Männer so wir
können das wir haben das alles schon und
einen Tag später beim Schreiben auf
Instagram auf dem Klo hat sich Schritt
zurück gemeldet danach hat Max angerufen
und ja ging los ich glaube es muss
wieder dieser Abfahrt sein es muss Wind
regnerisch kalt sein ich sehe auch eher
sowas wie da Kanada 14 Jungs hatten so
die Ideen ja man könnte ja was in Alaska
oder in Kanada machen und da kam von uns
einfach dann so der Appell so Jungs wenn
ihr das in Kanada und Alaska machen das
ist ein Wald das ist zwar in Kanada aber
der sieht genauso aus wie in Schweden
ihr braucht irgendwie was mit mehr Dampf
ihr braucht irgendwie was anderes ihr
braucht irgendwie Tropen ihr braucht
Dschungel hier ihr braucht eine einsame
Insel mit Tropen Regenwald so daraufhin
haben wir gesagt ja gut wenn ihr wisst
was ihr wollt dann macht uns doch gerne
meine PowerPoint Präsentation die
Kriterien sind die und die und ja
daraufhin hat Paddy eine allerfeinste
Präsentation uns bei discord 3
geklatscht die uns von Hocker gehauen
hat und uns auf zurückkommen lassen hat
es gab einige Punkte die definitiv
gewährleistet sein mussten um Staffel 2
wirklich auf einer tropischen Insel
umsetzen zu können die Insel muss völlig
isoliert sein um wirklich echtes wildes
survival zu garantieren darf dabei aber
nicht zu weit ab vom Schuss sein um bei
jedem Teilnehmer eine Rettung über Land
Wasser und auch Luft zu gewährleisten
insbesondere ein schneller und
reibungsloser Abtransport eines
Patienten in eine hoch ausgestattete
Klinik muss zwingend zu allen Tages- und
Nachtzeiten möglich sein dabei muss die
Insel groß genug sein damit sich die
Teilnehmer in keinem Falle treffen darf
aber wegen langer Rettungswege auch
nicht zu groß sein die Insel darf
außerdem nicht stark verbaut sein muss
aber trotzdem eine
Unterbringungsmöglichkeit fürs Team
bieten und ein Helikopter Landeplatz
haben es müssen natürlich genug
überlebenswichtige Ressourcen wie Wasser
und Nahrung verfügbar sein ohne es den
Teilnehmern zu leicht zu machen und die
Insel darf auf keinen Fall einer
torschutzgebiet sein was das Fällen von
Bäumen und Töten von Tieren vermieten
würde mit diesen Rahmenbedingungen ist
wandermut in die Recherche gegangen und
hat ihr gesamtes Netzwerk aktiviert um
in absolutem Rekordtempo von zwei Wochen
eine Auswahl von sieben Inseln in vier
verschiedenen Ländern hervorzubringen
nach feiner Recherche stellte sich doch
allerdings bei heraus dass sie wegen
Größe Rattenplage Entfernung zum
Festland oder Terrorgefahren nicht
geeignet sind außer bei einer Isla San
José im Süden von Panama ja und dann hat
sie das alles am Ende
gebündelt herausgestellt dass wir hier
alles haben dass wir hier ohne Probleme
das Team unterkriegen dass wir die
Rettungskette kriegen ist es so remote
irgendwo im Pazifik 80 km vor der Küste
das ist jetzt nicht so easy zu erreichen
ist man hat das Gefühl man man ist hier
einfach auf so einer tropischen Insel
wurden gestrandet ist aber nur hier 500
Meter raus gehst dann bist du im fucking
no where da ist nichts so da fühlst du
dich auch so in der Theorie schien diese
Insel hier perfekt zu sein aber was wir
nicht sehen konnten so auf
Satellitenbildern waren ob wir genügend
gute Spots an dieser Insel finden würden
also haben wir beschlossen hier einfach
mal hinzufahren und das Ganze
auszuschecken vor Ort Johannes und ich
war gerade im Urlaub und auf einmal
schrieben die Wanne und Jungs hey wir
fliegen nächste Woche nach Panama auf
Isa San José gucken uns das an wollt ihr
mitkommen Bucht euch einen Flug und
nicht los
[Applaus]
wie wird die zweite Staffel 7 was wild
noch abenteuerlicher diese Frage haben
wir uns gestellt und sind aus diesem
Grund in Panama City um für die Jungs
von Seven words wild herauszufinden ob
es möglich ist sich auf einem fliegenden
Helikopter aus 10 Metern Höhe ins Meer
werfen zu lassen um dort 7 Tage lang in
der Wildnis eine einsamen Insel zu
überleben das ganze ist natürlich nicht
ganz ungefährlich dort wimmelt es vor
Krokodilen und es gibt auch Haie rund um
die Insel also aus dem Hubschrauber zu
springen ist der See schon keine Sache
die wir empfehlen würden aber das macht
natürlich auch ein bisschen schwieriger
und um zu schauen ob das ganze dann auch
für die Teilnehmer funktioniert testen
wir das Ganze an und selbst Johannes was
haben wir denn in dieser Kiste drin was
nehmen wir denn mit auf die einsame
Insel
[Musik]
jetzt schon der erste Stress los wenn
der Taxifahrer nicht weiß wo er hin muss
und wir den Helikopter verpassen
hallo
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Scouting für
Staffel 2 von Samos wild wir fliegen
jetzt auf die exotische Insel mit
Krokodilen Hein giftigen schlagen und
giftigen Früchten und wir gucken was
passiert wir springen aus dem Heli let's
go
neben riesiger Vorfreude flog in diesem
Helikopter eine ordentliche Prise
Anspannung mit im Prinzip war Islas San
José die einzige vielversprechende
Option die dem seven vs wild Team und
Banner
mittlerweile war april und alle anderen
Standorte konnten schon aus der Ferne
ausgeschlossen werden würde diese Insel
also einen der wichtigen Punkte nicht
erfüllen oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen
nicht passen wäre die Zeit vor
Produktionsstart zu knappen
[Musik]
wir sind angekommen
dein Eindruck kein Problem das Ding ist
zum ersten Mal geflogen Herz aber guter
Vogel
das ist kalt es von wandern Verlust
drei Verträge zu unterschreiben ich bin
die Fresse
es war verabredet an einer bestimmten
Bucht diesen diesen Helikopter Jump
einfach mal zu testen auszuprobieren
wir haben diese Bucht auch gefunden aber
wir hatten uns auch mit einem
Rettungsboot verabredet weil ja gut so
oft sind wir jetzt auch noch nicht aus
dem Helikopter gesprungen wollten das
halt möglichst sicher testen und die
Bucht war halt so ausgewählt dass das
Boot und unser survival Instructor der
Tom vorher schon mal geguckt haben ob
das Wasser tief genug ist wie es halt
kam wäre irgendwie hat er Helikopter
Pilot sich verflogen Dinge passieren und
wir sind in einer anderen Bucht gelandet
eigentlich sollte hier ein Foto sein zum
spotten wenn wir hier aus Medicopter
springen der ist aber kein Boot und naja
wir mussten es halt irgendwie machen
haben gesagt sie kann kommen da jetzt
runter so was was soll's
Wald geht es nicht per se darum hör
weiter schneller sondern es geht darum
sagt anders zu machen deswegen haben wir
auch gesagt ey wir wollen andere
Location haben aber natürlich so eine
tropische Insel die bietet sich einfach
an dafür mit einem Knall rein zu starten
deswegen wollten wir unbedingt ein
Helikopter Job auf haben
keiner wusste ob das funktioniert das
überhaupt legal ist wie das
funktionieren kann
da gab es auch dann wirklich unzählige
Probleme im späteren Ablauf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
man kann auf jeden Fall mit diesem
Helikopter auf diese Insel fliegen man
kann da runterspringen ohne zu kreieren
und das funktioniert
ja mann das wird geil also genauso
sollte das interessieren ja
das war
das war echt scary weil wenn ich wussten
wie tief es ist aber der Baby ist da der
ist als erster gesprungen deswegen
alles tutti gelaufen
hast du hier Krokodile gesehen so
Krokodile haben wir bisher noch keine
gesehen aber die sind hier die sehen uns
wir sehen sie nicht
nach dem Helikopter run haben wir auch
das erste Mal gemerkt wie fucking teuer
in Helikopter ist also es ist ja sowas
abstraktes keiner von uns hat jemals für
so eine Produktion definierte Copter
gemietet also es ist das ist ja wirklich
Hollywood shit eigentlich was man auch
nicht erwartet bei so einer komischen
Youtube Geschichte ganz kurz das müsst
ihr euch vorstellen ein Helikopterflug
wie was sind 80 Kilometer 80 km
Helikopterflug ist teurer als zwei Flüge
von Deutschland nach Panama also es ist
also ich glaube was haben wir Zeit am
Ende ich glaube über 5000 € oder so für
diesen einen test run nur letztendlich
nur um zu gucken ob das überhaupt
irgendwie funktioniert und vielleicht
kennt Ihr das auch ihr habt etwas
gekauft das eigentlich gar nicht auf dem
Budget entspricht oder euch bei einem
Projekt etwas überschätzt und sei
dadurch jetzt in der Ratenzahlung oder
einem Verbraucherkredit gefangen aber
kein Problem Andy findet unterstützt
dich nur uns bei diesem Video sondern
noch euch bei eurem raten oder Kredit
Problem any finde hilft euch dabei aus
der Schuldenspirale auszubrechen und
einfach schneller bestehende Schulden
loszuwerden ja richtig bestehende
Schulden anifin richtet sich nämlich nur
an Personen die bereits in einem Kredit
drin hängen also schon verschuldet sind
und wirklich auch nur an die anifin kann
euch vielen Fällen ein Angebot mit
weniger Zinsen machen indem sie dafür
sorgen dass euer Kredit auf einmal
abbezahlt wird dadurch wird es nicht nur
günstiger sondern auch deutlich
flexibler weil ihr könnt in der App
selber einstellen in welchem Tempo
ihrraten zurückzahlen wollt und bis zu
zwei ratenpausen im Jahr einlegen aber
auch langfristig hilft euch eine finden
dabei euer Schuldenproblem in den Griff
zu bekommen sie geben euch
beispielsweise in der App die
Möglichkeit super einfach und mit nur
ein paar Klicks eure Kreditkarte
kündigen zu können damit ihr auch
langfristig nicht mehr in die versuchen
kommt irgendetwas zu kaufen das über
euren Budget liegt gerade momentan wo
super viele Kosten steigen ist es
natürlich umso wichtiger die unnötigen
kostenlos zu werden und die Zinskosten
sind sehr guter Anfang also klickt auf
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
benutzt Code Dave für 20 € Rabatt auf
eure erste Ratenzahlung und fangt an
euer Schlamassel aufzuhören vielen Dank
an any 5 fürs möglich machen dieses
Projekt ist und euch viel Spaß weiter
mit dem Video wir hatten schon zu Hause
am Computer mehrere Spots rausgesucht
wir hatten mit anderen Filmproduzenten
geredet haben da schon paar Tipps
bekommen hatten dann eine Liste von 13
14 Spots ungefähr und haben uns dann
Motorboot gemietet und sind dieses
thematisch abgefahren
[Musik]
also Familie jetzt im Boot und wir
gucken die ersten Spots an
die ersten möglichen spots
irgendwie wurden nicht vom Boot abgeholt
wie das
geplant um migrationsprobleme am Ende
kriegen wir doch wieder alles gelöst und
sind hier ordentlich am Scout
sieht schon sehr wild sehr cool
sehr viel Müll auch
Sonne geht langsam runter und wir sind
jetzt nicht mal zu einem Viertel um die
Insel rum also
so wir sind jetzt hier am zweiten Spot
angekommen und sind auf jeden Fall schon
ganz optimistisch gestimmt denn was wir
hier sehen sind ein Haufen Palmen mit
Kokosnüssen und wir damit kalkulieren
dass jeder zehn Kokosnüsse am Tag
braucht für
Kokosfleisch und die Kokosmilch sind das
ca 70 Kokosnüsse über die ganze Zeit und
das ist schon mal ein saugeiler
Indikator für einen guten Spot geil und
es macht optisch was her und ist sexy
Problem ist
hier ist alles von äh und das ist
etwas zu viel mehr für Minecraft
traurig alter das ist halt jetzt die
Realität ne also das hier
dieser Müll am ganzen Strand ist die
Realität Tom und Martin sind gerade noch
hier rumgerannt am Müll Spot und da ist
eine Straße zu hast also oder halt so
irgendeiner Straße
untergegangen morgen geht's weiter also
unser Ziel für heute ist es die sieben
finalen Spots zu finden dann nehmen wir
dann bald die Teilnehmer aussetzen
werden drei Dinge die wir heute ganz
besonders beachten müssen erstens
natürlich Spots finden bei denen wir
genug Ressourcen finden damit jeder
Teilnehmer auch dort überleben kann
zweitens wir müssen äh die Wassertiefe
checken dafür beschlossen dabei und
gucken dass wenn es zum Heli Drop auf an
diesen Spots kommt dass das Wasser auf
tief genug ist dass ich da nicht jeder
schon die hackenbricht wenn er aus dem
Helikopter springt und drittens wir
müssen
abschätzen ob die Wellen auch später im
Jahr klein genug sind um diesen Strand
noch im Notfall erreichen zu können denn
je nach Jahreszeit unterscheidet sich
auf die wellengröße und je nachdem wäre
dann ein Strand nicht mehr erreichbar
für uns also das ist der dritte Punkt
auf dem es heute ankommt
ein den wir noch nicht vorgestellt haben
ist Tom Thomas einer der Top Survivalist
der ganzen Welt bildet Leute wie jetzt
Stafford aus das sind deine Kameras
aktiv Tom but you active my name is Thal
Mercury i bin survival for Tony five use
of island to the champion
Fritz dieses Jahr mit seinem Know-how
aus der Serie genommen haben bei der
Planung brauchten wir ein Ersatz der uns
mit seinem Wissen zur Seite steht und
das war dieses Jahr Tom mcarroy krasser
Typ absoluter survival King also ich
glaube das hat man selten gesehen
Geisteskranke Skills beim Scouting
innerhalb von 10 Minuten hatte dann
Feuer an ohne ein Feuerzeug und
Feuerstahl hat die Kokosnüsse am Band
runtergeholt waren sie in der Typ kann
man viel von lernen wir sind sehr froh
dass er dabei ist
[Musik]
so den Steinstrand schauen wir uns jetzt
mal an
was so ein bisschen Sorgen macht ist
dass wir jetzt noch nicht so viele
Kokosnuss Palmen sehen aber vielleicht
finden sich da hinten zum Beispiel die
eine oder andere noch aber schauen wir
mal ob der taugt
na sind die Eier nass ja ja das was die
Teilnehmer auch durchmachen macht man ja
selber auch durch ja klar
da hinten sehen wir schon irgendwo eine
Palme stehen und die können wir ab
ernten das wäre auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen was an Ressourcen hier überall
so schön die Insel auch ist wird Müll
angeschwemmt
so ist die Realität
ja das ist die Realität
s one
the raining
challenge because the tide becoming
everyday
trees
any Crocodile
das ist keine Hänger ins Bad
hier
also sehen wir optimal es war optisch
ganz ganz interessant aber die
Ressourcen sehen einfach scheiße aus
Groß mollige Nachbarn da vorne sind safe
Krokodile und die Flut wird halt auch
alles wegnehmen hier sobald sie
wiederkommt insofern ist das ein Backup
Spot und es wird sicherlich geilere
geben
aber ja Worst Case könnte es einer
werden ich als Teilnehmer wird mich hier
abpacken wenn ich hier landen würde aber
gehen tut
wir wollen nicht auf dieser Insel
zurückbleiben
also harte Arbeit dass ich natürlich
immer den Martin vor einfach den größten
Bizeps sorry einer muss
entschieden dass wir lieber die Ostseite
der Insel anschauen aufgrund der Wellen
sind einfach zu hoch hier und ähm ja in
der in der Regel Saison werden sie noch
höher das heißt die Safety Kette wäre da
einfach
nicht mehr geil zu gewährleisten
deswegen ballern wir jetzt einmal
komplett auf den anderen Teil der Insel
auf die Ostseite und schauen wie es da
aussieht
tschüss Schwester Seite
[Musik]
wie sieht's aus da hinten
ist geil dicker aber das sieht dir krank
aus ne jetzt sind wir hier an Spot
Nummer vier ein möglicher Spot
Kiesstrand oben haben wir Frischwasser
relativ wenig Kokosnüsse Traum absolut
hier gibt es alles ist der beste Spotify
Wasser geht
[Musik]
ja das ist die bittere Pille die wir
auch schlucken müssen man hat solche
Locations hier
traumhafte Wasserfälle Frischwasser
sieht alles herrlich aus das Problem ist
wenn wir einmal kurz rumguckt man kommt
hier gar nicht weg also da müsstest du
jetzt eine Stahlwand von 20 m hoch
klettern um überhaupt mal rauszukommen
um mal irgendwas zu fressen zu finden
oder so deswegen leider raus obwohl es
so schön ist war zwar ein Versuch wert
jetzt noch mal 100 Meter weiter zu
gucken aber der Spot von eben ist
einfach geiler hoffnungslos
[Musik]
auch wieder Rocky Beach
einmal hier in dieses Valle hier rein zu
gucken okay
easy ist das Gelände hier nicht
so anstrengend aber jetzt haben wir vier
Spots hier von 10 weil wir wollen sieben
sichere Sports und drei Ausweis Spots
falls dann doch irgendwas schief läuft
also haben wir ein bisschen was vor uns
aber es geht voran
[Musik]
wir befinden uns hier gerade im Norden
der Insel an einem Spot den wir zufällig
gefunden haben wir fahren hier gerade
die Küste ab
bitte lass diesen Spot gut sein
so happiers
Larry's fresh water hier ist fließendes
Wasser perfekt
derjenige der den bekommt hat auf jeden
Fall ein Joker so der Beweis
Fischen geht auf jeden Fall ja mal so
die Flosse einfach
[Musik]
das ist so mein spot
ein Kopf platzt
[Applaus]
Paradise mit
Kokosnuss
schon geil
wie aus dem Rewe
Selbsttest hier am traumspot der
schönste Spot den wir bisher gefunden
haben versuch mal die Kokosnuss jetzt zu
knacken wenn ich schon offen ist ist er
nicht dasselbe oder
es geht auch mit Kraft einfach nur ohne
Werkzeug
also hier ist sowieso eine Landzunge mit
einem Strand links am Strand rechts ja
hier ist wohl der nördlichste Punkt der
Insel hier wäre zum Beispiel der Spot
wenn man jetzt hoch geht
ist halt alles nur Dschungel ne bis bald
[Applaus]
keine
Giants
Wellings
about this island this that you want to
be passing in today's world is always
gonna Beat is
minori very very coming and fortunally
Thorsten Kalorien Survivor
hier sind die Crocs
sagen
[Musik]
einer zweiten Staffel 1
ich denke man kann jetzt schon sagen im
heutigen Tage das ist
[Musik]
sehr sehr geil
am Ende des scoutings saßen wir dann mit
den wandermut Jungs in Hacienda und dann
waren wir uns wirklich ziemlich schnell
einig ey das ist es hier wir haben die
Hacienda gesehen wir wussten wir können
ja das Team unterbringen was aber auch
wiederum bedeutet wir müssen diese
Riesen Insel mieten inklusive der
Hacienda der Hotelanlage damit das ganze
Team hier unterbringen können
ja aber wir haben gesagt komm wir machen
das wir haben uns die ersten Preise
reingeholt wo wir dann beide hinten
übergefallen sind natürlich ja der erste
Kostenvoranschlag geisteskrank wenn man
dann hört dass die Insel Miete für den
Zeitraum wo wir sie brauchen wie schon
im sechsstelligen Bereich liegt ist
einfach krank das sind auch Summen mit
den hantieren wir nicht täglich das ist
einfach utopisch für uns eigentlich aber
dennoch habe gesagt ey das ist es
irgendwie jetzt noch mal was anderes zu
suchen wäre auch einfach zeitlich super
super eng geworden dann hat die
Ressourcen man kann die Rettungskette
auf die Beine stellen man kann es so
sicher wie nur möglich machen
wir wollten die Insel costes was es
wolle die Insel war absolut perfekt was
alles Bots angeht was die Ressourcen
angehen was sie will morgen das angehen
aber wir sollten trotzdem noch eine böse
Überraschung erleben und zwar hat Isla
San José eine sehr dunkle Vergangenheit
in den 40ern wurden die Waffen getestet
bei diesem Test sind nicht immer alle
das heißt im Umkehrschluss nach
Berichten von Journalisten das bis zu
3000 der getesteten Bomben nicht
gezündet sind nach dem Tests gab es
einen cleanup der von den Amerikanern
durchgeführt wurde aber auch hier sind
sie Journalisten die das Thema behandelt
haben nicht sicher wie gründlich dieser
wirklich war desto mehr nährten sich da
irgendwo die Zweifel und das ganze
hatten wir dann thematisiert in einem
Call den wir mit Max und Johannes hatten
und es wirklich ernste Bedenken gab es
Notfall notfallpaddy was soll das grüne
Hölle Alter das kannst Du halt nicht
bringen wenn da irgendein Typ auf dem
Blindgänger läuft denn in die Luft geht
für uns war das natürlich fundamental
wichtig dass Maximum an Sicherheit für
unsere Teilnehmer zu haben wir müssen
irgendwie rausfinden wie hoch die Gefahr
wirklich ist eine Sache die wir gelesen
hatten war das ist testsonen auf der
Insel gab und zwar wurden diese Tests
nicht komplett auf den Insel
durchgeführt sondern in sechs
verschiedenen Zonen jetzt war für uns
die Herausforderung okay wie schaffen
wir es diese testsonen rauszubekommen
denn das waren amerikanische Dokumente
und du konntest nur daran kommen wenn du
als Amerikaner einen Antrag gestellt
hattest und auch dann musstest du
wochenlang warten diese Zeit hatten wir
einfach nicht der Lounge von severse
Wild rückte näher und wir brauchten halt
wirklich schnell irgendeine Lösung die
einzige Möglichkeit die uns denn den
Sinn kam war okay wir müssen den
investigativ-journalisten erreichen
vielleicht hat er Zugang zu dieser Karte
habt ihr dann angerufen du hattest dann
früh morgens irgendwo so ein
verschlafenen amerikanischen
Journalisten am Telefon
die ersten Fragen waren wir wer bist du
hast du einen Termin was willst du von
mir hören sie auf mich zu belästigen und
wir waren da so wir brauchen einfach
dringend eine Lösung und das ist echt
nicht meine Art in welchen Leuten auf
dem Pelz zurück Rücken aber ich war so
nee es geht um die Sicherheit von
unserem Team wir brauchen diese
Informationen und wir brauchen die jetzt
naja und coolerweise hat er sich dann
noch breit schlagen lassen da irgendwo
zwei Stunden später sowohl den OPCW
cleanup Bericht rüber zu schicken als
auch die Karte mit den Test Sohn und das
war dann abends für uns die Lösung wir
konnten halt genau sehen okay die sechs
Tests und die waren im Inland die
teilnehmerspots sind nicht davon
betroffen dann haben wir später auch
noch Wasserproben bekommen die waren
auch alle in Ordnung und dann mussten
wir okay wir sind get to go ich glaube
das ist natürlich erstmal krass wenn du
das hörst und denkst du ey das können
wir nicht machen wir können ja keine
Leute im Dschungel schicken wenn er
irgendwelche bildgänge herumliegen aber
zum Glück hat Paddy sich da richtig rein
geknetet hat da endlose Recherchen
angestellt ja und hat uns wirklich ganz
ganz viel Sorge nehmen können
[Musik]